a team made up of all Indian origin
players just pulled off one of the
biggest upsets in basketball this summer
Team India Rising just competed in the
basketball tournament this Second Street
year which is a single elimination open
tournament for anyone that features a
top prize of 1 million dollars they came
in as the eighth seed and took down the
number ones they were a 15-point
underdog and they still won while the
team does have Semi-Pro and college
players many of the players have second
jobs as doctors and Engineers while they
have Ambitions of winning the tournament
their main goal was to inspire the next
generation of South Indian basketball
players and even if they lose their next
game it's safe to say that with this win
they put the whole world on notice